well we're talking about uh social media
manipulation
and i think this should segue us into
our next really major story
oh yeah clarence thomas blasts section
230 wants common carrier rules for
twitter
thomas claims twitter's right to cut off
speech raises first amendment problem
this is an amazing story do you guys
remember when trump got sued for
blocking people
yeah what vaguely no there was here's
the thing
probably i'm i'm not gonna say i didn't
pay attention to it maybe i did but
there were so many trump stories that
it's like they've all just kind of
they're gone now they're all out of my
head they just got washed right out
as soon as he left office i was like
that's it don't need to remember any of
this
like dumbledore with a pencil just like
you took your pizzagates
don't i'm gonna get a generational
spirit if you could talk about harry
potter i can't
okay so trump got sued and this court
ruled trump can't block people
and it was like one of the stupidest
rulings to a lot of people were like
that's dumb
because twitter is a private business
and how could it be a public forum
here's the ruling trump tweets it
creates a public forum where people can
reply
so if trump bans them it's violating
their first amendment right
so we can't do that then all people are
like but twitter's a private company and
twitter can remove that yeah
and twitter did start putting
restrictions so how can you call it a
public forum created
when a private company has a right to
remove this the way i viewed it was like
imagine donald trump holds and holds an
event
open to the public but hires a private
security contractor
so what the private security company can
kick people out and viola
protesters show up oh but it's a private
security company you know they're the
ones running this event and control
things
they have the authority to remove people
so it's not a violation of your first
amendment rights
if you're protesting the president and a
private company removes you so the
courts ruled
trump can't remove you but a private
company can yeah makes no sense
so it actually got upheld on appeal then
it made its way to the supreme court
where they dismissed it and vacated the
ruling congratulations if you're a
politician like aoc
you can now block people again because
she was also implicated in this because
she was blocking people
here's what gets crazy though the whole
thing's backfiring the left wanted the
regulation
and with this ruling clarence thomas
issued this massive opinion
i mean massive in terms of the like the
impact it may end up having he issued
his opinion which will have a massive
impact
in my opinion where he said that how is
it that a private company like twitter
can ban the president but you know these
courts are claiming it's it's a first
amendment issue
maybe these are not platforms in fact
they're common carriers like phone
companies here's here's what i'm saying
the rules for section 230 for those
aren't familiar basically say
a web service platform can't be held
responsible for the things that users
say
you've got to sue the user long story
short
if i have a uh if if sheamus has a
a blog let's say you set up a blog where
you write articles about religion
and you you have a comment section so
that people can respond to you and give
you thoughts
and you have rules where you're like
this is specifically for talk on
christianity and our opinions it makes
sense in my opinion then
to ban people who violate your rules
because the point of your website is for
you sheamus to publish
not for the comments those are ancillary
those are peripheral to the main
objective
twitter's express purpose is users
commenting and posting things yeah which
is more like a phone company
yes imagine if like you went to verizon
for a phone
not to talk to people but to hear what
the ceo of verizon wanted to tell you
right it's very different you know what
i mean oh but you can't call someone but
every day you open your phone and
there's the ceo talking
and then you can like well i think
you're dumb that's that's more like what
what
they're trying to claim you know what i
mean it's kind of how these android
phones are i don't think google doesn't
hit me with an ad every time i open my
phone but there are google ads well that
is just
they are just burning money so they
don't do that right don't don't
the libertarians got mad at me though uh
oh no
the libertarian party of texas said it
was horrible for free speech
because a company was being the
government was getting in the way this
is the this is the weirdest thing to me
about the
the big l libertarian position on this
why is it that
the big l libertarian party is
pro-authoritarianism unless
as long as it's coming from corporations
it's really very weird yeah is it
right so i'm little libertarian meaning
i overwhelmingly just want the
individual to be protected
when a massive multinational corporation
is dumping money into politics
and manipulating the the the ability for
people to speak and get their
you know representatives elected that's
authoritarianism and i'm not okay with
that well yeah it would be one thing if
it was like a totally
completely free private market then it
would make some sense to be like no they
have to be
protected and we can't break them up but
there's so much state involvement
already
that it seems as if state involvement in
the direction of helping people to
express themselves instead of
allowing the big tech companies to do
whatever they want and be supported in
that decision is probably
uh more in line with a lot of the
classically liberal principles
libertarians have
agree or disagree with them you can't
break up twitter though
twitter works as a service because of
its ubiquity yeah
if you broke up twitter into like 10
services nobody would want to use any of
these services because like
who would you be following unless they
were forced into the fetaverse
then it would make sense but you can't
break up google or twitter in the same
way you can bring up google because
google has a bunch of different
companies like
google search can't be broken up they
dominate search period
nothing you can do about it however
google you know alphabet also owns an ad
network
add sales they run ads they buy ads
and they've got you know g suite they've
got calendar they've got all these
yeah all of these different areas that
do a bunch of different crazy things you
could break that up
so in terms of of big tech what i see is
the usefulness of social media is in its
monopolistic tendencies not in terms of
abuse of its users but in the fact that
everybody uses one service to
communicate
so that's that's why i'm very much in
favor of it needs to be regulated
there's not going to be twitter too
parlor almost came about and got crushed
yeah so that's that's where it's really
bad it's not about antitrust it's about
what is this rico is a racketeering what
do you call it when all these companies
come together
and they collude to stifle any
competition hostile takeover
no it's just it's trust violations and
stuff like that right
yeah bad stuff hostile taker is when you
buy a company out right
yeah those were made illegal in the 19th
early 1900s no i think they still happen
what do you mean well they're supposed
to be illegal
they buy up as much much shares as
possible until they have controlling
majority and then they take it yeah they
ruin the value
which is what those those horrible
redditors did to gamestop it was very
simple
well did you hear that they're going to
be issuing new stock really
they just started over gamestop i think
announced that they had a bump in sales
and they were going to be doing a stock
offering
and then a bunch of people started
selling because a stock offering means
the short sellers have an exit however
the stock still isn't like 200 bucks so
really yeah it's still really high right
now
yeah i'm surprised it didn't it didn't
take a dive my thoughts on this free
speech thing
is that i've never heard of a
corporation upholding free speech
in the in the history of the world that
is what the united states government was
built for
so obviously i think we should rely on
the government for this one
the the government doesn't guarantee
free speech the government is prohibited
from infringing upon free speech oh okay
so when people
the republic the libertarian party
responded to me on twitter and they were
like you think the problem will be like
it'll be made better with government
involvement
and i'm like the government involvement
goes so far as saying you can't do that
not that they're gonna show up to the
twitter's headquarters nationalized
twitter
yeah yeah and then you send your tweet
out and they give you a tracking number
like it'll be up in two weeks
right the government is like it's in it
your inalienable right is the freedom to
speech now we're going to make sure
people don't infringe on that yeah it's
not it's not about the government
working at twitter
it's about a pathway to a lawsuit it's
about the government saying
you can sue over this that's that's it
and there's also something to be said
for
even if you left the system the way it
was now for the terms of service to to
be applied equitably
that's a good point because there are so
many people who have said things which
are horrifically violent but it's in the
direction of
assaulting conservatives like i mean we
saw this a lot not to beat a dead horse
but hey some dead horses needs their
need their butts kicked this is a pretty
serious topic the whole nick sandman
story is the perfect example you had
like grown adults jumping on this kid no
one has a more punchable face and
you should put them in a wood chipper
psychotic stuff like that and
they weren't banned yeah but then trump
was like you're my special boys and
you're very peaceful
and then they deleted trump completely
off the planet screaming at the top of
their lungs getting rid of them
so here's what's going to happen uh what
could happen with clarence thomas
it doesn't do anything they dismissed
this case they vacated the previous
ruling but
clarence thomas's opinion could be used
in a lawsuit or
as a justification for regulation of
these platforms through congress
i really doubt congress would do
anything because surprise surprise the
left is not in favor of free speech when
it's
their enemies that are being censored so
there's potential there's potential for
a lawsuit i suppose
under clarence thomas's opinion someone
could now sue and say here's
what clarence thomas said what would
they sue exactly what would they sue for
so it's interesting i've seen a bunch of
arguments
and they tend to fail for for a variety
of reasons but
when you sign up for twitter you're
entering into a contract with twitter as
well as
tweet as like you're both in a contract
you're both parties to this agreement
now twitter and most platforms say we
reserve the right to ban anyone for any
reason
and that basically you know cuts you off
you can't really do much
but the general idea we've seen from
some people is we entered into agreement
and twitter
violated that by removing me for for
fake reasons
the other thing however that i think is
being overlooked by people
is that twitter should be sued for
defamation and libel
when someone gets banned so for instance
when milo got suspended i think
they said something like he was running
multiple accounts okay
so they should have said if that's not
true if that's not true
then milo should sue for defamation for
libel saying they issued this statement
to the press it's not true could you
imagine if they started being like we're
going to ban this person for no reason
if that was their public statement but
what if they had to say that or it was
defamation
this person were banning for no reason
what if like they run out of people to
ban
because they've just gotten rid of all
their political opponents but like the
the twitter ceos just they still need
blood
and so they just like start picking
random accounts to be sacrificed every
year
as tribute they just like just some dude
named greg they're just like tweeting
his like is just like he's just like
tweeting
benign stuff and they're like your
account has to go they just like will
randomly grab people and remove them
from the platform
for tribal reasons the left has to
support it yeah and so they all just
like they're like
eliminate greg just in unison they're
like goodbye greg
it's like racist we just started
cancelling people
like people fall so in line with the
narrative
that you can't find anyone to cancel so
they just have to randomly select people
for canceling
and like everyone's like wearing their
like cult hoods they're like cancel greg
you have to clap yeah exactly no you
have to cancel greg you have to snap
snap clapping remember clapping yeah
yeah you have to do just flapping them
out you just snap
this clapping is a problem yeah oh my
goodness soy clap when you clap between
words
is that oh that's right but let me tell
you i i have to be honest
that does make me appreciate someone's
opinion more when they have this claps
between it i'm like this guy
he knows something that i don't what
what is the clapping thing and why do
people do it
i don't know i think it's a power grab
like a cool guy thing
i'm making noise or they like singing
like i don't know
like when they're being loud like i
think this
thing like you are really i always
imagine like you're going like
i'll be with you like they're clapping
along to the music you know i mean
it could be i did i was guilty of
earlier i think when i was telling
people to smash the like button i was
doing a little bit of a clap it just
gets the people going
smash the like button and they do it
because you clap and that means you have
authority
yes clapping mm-hmm yeah clap on please
clap
we could have had you all that's all we
had to do is clap but now we don't have
jeb bush thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you